uh i will say though at uh you know i'll
be 60 this year i'm a little like
tony randall having kids i will say that
there's times when i go
when they're when like they say okay now
we're gonna you know hop like a frog all
the way to bed
i'm like i'll hop a few
i'm going all the way to the bedroom so
you know
i'll hop right in george um you really
caused a big problem and you know that
and
i think you understand it that flow
flowbies aren't available
anymore oh i know years ago uh
i bought a a thing called the flowbee
which when we did not when i was a kid
yeah the infomercial the flowbee this
ingenious device lets you give yourself
and family
perfect haircuts every time so why would
you throw that out there and do you
really use a flowbee
yeah yeah you know it requires two plugs
because one's the vacuum and one's the
the trimmer yeah
yeah i i believe me you know my wife i
think
a few years ago when she first saw me
using she came in she heard this sound
it sounds like a
a hurricane and she goes what are you
doing i'm cutting my hair
um yeah yeah i know i should have bought
stock in the company before i said
anything
you know i screwed up yeah um does she
let you put that thing near the kids at
all
no but i do cut my son's hair um
yeah i have to cut his hair not with a
flowbee though but i i have to cut his
hair because it's you know
you know i don't i wanted to be able to
see
you know but yeah you listen we're all
doing all kinds of stuff just to
get through you know it's crazy is this
was
this movie different for you now that
you have your children and
and for me i just i just thought about
like at the time this movie is set and
it's right when my children will be
growing to adulthood and i'm like oh
damn this is a situation in our galaxy
alone there are billions of stars
at least one of them has the potential
to support
life well yeah i mean i
you know certainly the idea of you know
when you're having children
it makes you infinitely even more aware
of the idea that
what we're leaving them and what legacy
we're leaving them and whether we're
going to deny
science or whether we're going to have a
world of
divisiveness and anger and hatred and
not just in this country all around the
world and what those elements can lead
to if they're allowed to
fester so you know i i i
certainly am aware of that and was aware
of it when i was telling the story
it's not something that i wasn't aware
of without having children but it gets
sort of
put on steroids when you have kids yeah
um
what did your kids think of that beard
and what was it like once being the
sexiest man alive and then putting on
that father time beard
not once being said so just be clear
twice being sexy twice right
you know that's not messed up right um
well my my wife and my daughter were
really happy to see it go
my son he like because there were things
you know i would go to work
after playing with the kids in the
morning i'd go to work
and i'd be sitting there and you know
about to do a scene
and i'd go like this i i reach in and
there'd be like a popsicle stick in my
beard
you know not like not like a note that
says i love you papa like
you know something gooey george i i find
that once you
once you have your kids you find out
this is the greatest thing i wish i had
done
more in earlier do you feel that way now
well i guess not since i met my wife uh
you know
it's probably best that i did it with
with when i met my wife so
uh i will say though at you know i'll be
60 this year i'm a little like
tony randall having kids you know i uh
i i i will say that there's times when i
go
when they're when like they say okay now
we're gonna you know hop like a frog all
the way to bed
i'm like i'll i'll hop a few
i'm making so you know
hey um making this movie i heard that
there was a fitness trainer that
the folks who did the space walking they
really worked out did you ever think of
joining in
no i was really really you know i'd lost
about 25 pounds for this
so i was pretty weak i didn't need a
fitness trainer you know at that point i
was just trying to
you know trying to stay in that
spot which is not eating and you know
it's not it's not it's a lot harder the
older you get to do those things to
transform yourself in a way
so it gets trickier you know it gets
really easy to put weight on and a lot
harder to take it off you know
there you go ain't that the truth hey um
how was iceland
and how was it filming the scenes in the
brutal cold
well first of all iceland is just one of
the most amazing places
on earth and again you know it's an
interesting thing
um you know anybody who wants to sort of
talk about climate change and deny it
go to the places that are the front
lines of this you know
those glaciers are melting at an insane
rate
uh go to the maldives it's sinking you
know in
the water you know the places that are
on the front lines will really tell you
that you feel that
from everyone in iceland um but boy it's
a beautiful place to be
and uh and it was rough to shoot as you
can imagine we were out on this glacier
and it's cold and it's and you know
you're waiting for the wind because it's
really clear it's as clear as day
it's a beautiful day and so those aren't
snow
no stones those are wind storms that are
kicking up the snow
so you see it coming like a dust dust
bowl that's coming towards you
and you're like go here we go everybody
get together we're all tied to one
another because
you could lose each other literally
you'd see your hand in front of your
face
so we're tied to each other and i've got
a hold of kalyn's hand and there we go
and
here it comes ready and you just go and
then it just comes blasting like a
tornado through you
that is crazy hey um what are you
looking forward to in 2021
to get 20 20 behind what are you looking
forward to in 2021 besides that big
birthday
yeah i'm not looking for you know look
you never look forward to 60.
the alternative is dead so i'll take it
but yeah
um well look i feel like we all
should be looking forward to the idea
that there
is light at the end of this tunnel you
know there is
there's two three you know
the johnson johnson vaccine comes in
we're gonna have
four uh vaccines um
by you know probably by uh
late spring early summer we'll be
getting a lot more people vaccinated
than just the
essential workers who've been amazing um
so there's there is light at the end of
this tunnel and you know you just want
everybody to hang in there and
and you know it's tough and it's brutal
and all of those things is tough on the
economy it's all that
and the you know the government should
help out for everyone who's
who's having a difficult time but we're
all it's like you're swimming
nine tenths away across the ocean you
don't turn around and start swimming the
other way back we're close
and when we're there we're gonna you
know we'll be able to
we'll be able to be in the same room
again and uh which would be fantastic
they'll be back at school and we'll be
having uh you know
uh and we'll be all together and you'll
be able to see your family and i'll be
able to spend time with my mom and dad
yeah hey one last quick question
i'm married to a civil rights attorney
you're married to an
international civil rights attorney do
you sometimes look at your wife and be
like
damn how is she so much smarter than me
oh i don't have to even
you know everyone tells me that before i
even have to say it
yeah no listen it's it i i will tell you
that
she's gorgeous and funny
and all the things that people sort of
you know throw
to the side and talk about her
intelligence but her but she's the
smartest person in the room
in every room she walks in and it's i'm
always very proud to
to be standing next to her
you